en France 24 hablamos de economía y por
ello me acompañan el estudio mi
compañera Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida vamos a hablar de todos estos
temas de fin de semana vamos a empezar
con un fenómeno presente en América
Latina y el Caribe la discriminación
laboral Así es Valentina pues mire la
caf que es el banco de desarrollo de
América Latina publicó recientemente su
reporte de economía y desarrollo en el
que destaca Las barreras de acceso al
mercado laboral que enfrentan millones
de trabajadores de la región y todo esto
por su raza una de las conclusiones del
documento es que cuando Cuanto más
oscuro es el color de piel mayor es la
probabilidad de estar desempleado para
entender la dimensión de ese problema
nosotros contactamos a la gerente de
conocimiento de la Cafe yaz Verónica
friz ancho y le preguntamos pues qué tan
determinante es el color de la piel
justamente a la hora de conseguir un
trabajo formal
las personas con color de piel más
oscuro tienen no solo limitantes para
conseguir un trabajo formal sino
conseguir un trabajo en en general el
tema es que la etnia y la raza se
convierten en atributos que se
transmiten de generación a generación y
perpetúan discriminación en el mercado
laboral y desventajas históricas que
sufren los grupos de afrodescendientes y
de los indígenas en la región de hecho
nosotros estamos encontrando que si
comparas a la gente de piel más oscura
en la región versus la gente de piel más
clara en promedio hay una desventaja de
siete puntos porcentuales en cuanto a su
tasa de desempleo
Si vemos otras dimensiones del mercado
laboral Como por ejemplo la probabilidad
de trabajar por cuenta propia o ser
independiente Esta es mayor según el
color de piel se vuelve más oscuro y
también este grupo tiene una menor
probabilidad ocupar cargo gerenciales o
de ser dueños de su propio de su propia
empresa de su propio negocio y
obviamente menor probabilidad de
alcanzar cargos profesionales o técnicos
es todo está muy entrelazado Daniela una
problemática sumamente grada que no
siempre la damos O sea no damos esto por
sentado no y muy pocas veces se abordan
esta clase de temas es verdad Bueno
además de la discriminación laboral Qué
otros factores inciden para que América
Latina se considere como una de las
regiones del mundo más desiguales pues
Valentina no solamente el color de la
piel es un factor de desigualdad Aunque
ya lo veíamos que sí la capa evidenció
también que existen marcadas diferencias
salariales en determinadas por la región
o por la ciudad en cada país se comparó
la situación de las ciudades donde se
pagan Los sueldos más altos con las de
Los sueldos más bajos y esto fue lo que
encontraron las brechas o inequidades
más grandes están en Uruguay Perú Panamá
y México mientras que en Argentina
Bolivia Brasil y chile estas brechas son
Menores en tres ciudades Aunque siguen
siendo muy altas ahora están los
habitantes de pequeñas ciudades o
provincias condenados a ganar menos
salario que quienes viven en las grandes
urbes esto nos respondió nuestra
invitada
Lamentablemente habrá una persistencia
de estas inequidades en la medida en que
los hijos vivan en la misma ciudad en la
misma localidad que vivieron sus padres
porque no cambian las oportunidades
laborales mucho en el tiempo a través de
ciudades o a través de Urbano rural o a
través de barrios incluso no
en el reporte lo que encontramos Es que
este mecanismo de reproducción de la
desigualdad es de primer orden en
Latinoamérica más de la mitad de los
adultos que que encontramos en en los
datos disponibles para la región viven
el mismo municipio departamento o
localidad donde vivían sus padres
entonces Esto hace que las mismas
oportunidades que tenían tus padres las
experimentas tú como hijo una vez que
estás en el mercado laboral grave
Daniela y cómo está la región en materia
de distribución de ingresos y de riqueza
en América Latina Las barreras de acceso
a empleos formales también se reflejan
en una inequitativa distribución de los
recursos Esto no es noticia pero sí hay
que recordarlo pues siguen quedando en
pocas manos con base en el reporte de la
caf le preguntamos a nuestra invitada si
este fenómeno está en aumento en el
reporte lo que hacemos Es tratar de
medir la concentración tanto en ingresos
como de activos y encontramos
efectivamente lo que dice es que
la riqueza los activos están en muy
pocas manos es aún más marcada la
concentración que la concentración de
ingresos no
Y también encontramos esto que desde
mediados de los 80 esta concentración ha
ido aumentando la riqueza en manos del
del percentil más alto de riqueza en
Latinoamérica
era del orden del 28% en 1980 hoy hacia
finales de las décadas del 2010 el 1%
más rico concentra un tercio más de un
tercio de la riqueza
de la región los más pobres tienen
acceso a una cuenta de ahorros muy
básica con una tasa de interés muy baja
pasiva mientras que los más ricos tienen
a su alcance una serie de instrumentos
financieros como mayores retornos en los
mercados financieros entonces creo que
hay muchísimos factores por lo que esto
se está haciendo más grande y
probablemente continúe creciendo esta
brecha Valentina no es nuevo entonces
que América Latina sea desigual pero sí
es nuevo que está aumentando esa
desigualdad finalmente este estudio hizo
una comparación entre algunas de las
economías más grandes y encontró que por
ejemplo Colombia México Uruguay y chile
presentan altos niveles de desigualdad
de la riqueza y del ingreso lo que se
traduce en serias inequidades sociales
Daniela Pues a usted muchas gracias por
esta ampliación y por exponer esta
problemática aquí en France 24 acá nos
vemos en una próxima oportunidad así es
y a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
quédense con nosotros que hay más